[ __ ] sal oh i didn't even play this
you know how sal keeps saying he gets
messages from birds
he's gotten so into birds that he
started claiming that he knows by the
chirping what kind of bird it is and we
were like [ __ ] you sal oh come on so we
played them like for a bit we've played
them five different birds chirping the
[ __ ] identified every single one
of them
the bit was on us
i'm not kidding the bit was on us so
tell me
what bird this is
that's easy that my friend is the
sparrow
so tell me
what bird this is
no need to go any further my friend
that is the mockingbird
the next bird
my favorite bird of all time the red
cardinal this bird
stop the tape
morning dove and how about this bird
my beautiful
angelic
gorgeous
blue jay
you hear the call do you hear the fan
call when it's
listen
now the right time but at the beginning
oh yeah you're here we
in the back that's another it's another
blue jay responding he's all in on these
birds he really got that all right he
doesn't know the way the potato famine
happened but he sure is on those birds
civil war forget about but birds he
knows he's been working on bird calls
too he wants to talk to the birds can he
make any good bird sounds can he emulate
a bird
what is that
that's a mockingbird i could do kind of
a bird tell me what this is sal you
ready
that's right
i don't know what it is i'm just guys
oh this is a package why does howard
know what it is here's a parrot you
ready thousand [ __ ]
that's great that's definitely a parrot
all right what bird is this you ready
that's the style governale bird
you